how's it going guys Matt here with code
Tech and tutorials we're going to show
you how to make height map terrain and
with blender and [ __ ] today so all three
programs all free stuff
um this is just kind of my method that
I've learned so take it with whatever
grain of salt you need to take it with
don't expect me to be an expert I'm not
an expert at blender or uh [ __ ] I'm a C
plus plus programmer but as many of you
know I'm making a game so I'm often
toying around with this kind of stuff
too
if we want to make a height map terrain
first we need some sort of height map
and we're just going to do a black and
white height map you can often download
these online off websites or you can
make your own but in general we want to
use black and white and we mean we want
the darkest color to be low Terrain in
the brightest whitest color to be high
terrain so with that in mind we can make
gradients that essentially operate uh
like mountains and rivers and lakes and
stuff like that all right so let's get
started let's just make a new image I
pressed Ctrl n here on again so on
obviously you're gonna need [ __ ] and
blender I'm expecting you know how to do
that so image size you can kind of do
whatever you want here depending on what
resolution you want I'm just going to do
512 by 512 a nice even square and I'm
starting out with this I have these
colors set over here but uh
it doesn't really matter we're gonna
we're gonna do some blending and pull
some tricks to mess around with this so
I'm just going to kind of show you that
this being all gray right now
um it's not the brightest it could be
it's not the it's not the darkest it can
be so this is going to be just a mid
level but let's say you know we gotta we
got this all selected let's do control a
control a to select all here and let's
just go to filters and let's uh let's do
something interesting here there's quite
a few different ways we could kind of do
this I like to just make some kind of uh
some kind of noise pattern to start you
can really kind of mess around and just
get you something that you might like
under render there are a few things like
fractals noise
patterns so you can just pick something
there like let's go with some purlin
noise and check out what we get here we
get kind of this
I would say almost denim looking pattern
which is probably fine to start you know
it's going to give us a variety but
we've got some options here and we can
kind of adjust those as as we think like
maybe something like that that's going
to give us some some low zones with the
darks
um
scale here but really you basically just
kind of want to mess around with this
isn't going to necessarily matter a
whole lot okay so that looks maybe like
a fine start and then we're just going
to go to filters do a gaussian blur
we're gonna go to I don't know let's do
some other stuff maybe let's mess around
now you can always hit cancel if you
don't like the option you chose I like
to do cartoon modifier here under
artistic because it basically just makes
the blacks and whites more pronounced
sometimes that's a cool thing to do last
okay here we're getting something kind
of cool you can see that this might be
like a Terrain with a bunch of lakes and
maybe a swampy type area
so this might be a good base so this is
really just for base string obviously
this is not going to place trees or
Shrubbery or whatever it's just a height
map the height map only okay so maybe
let's go with this that looks kind of
cool a lot of low zones
um some high zones and then we could do
some other interesting stuff here like
maybe we could put a light on it and
choose Sparkle I guess
and uh let's see how this is looking
can't even really see
but basically if you put like a super
light Point somewhere it's going to make
a high Zone and well you're probably
getting the point here it's all looking
kind of random
um and you can really do this however
you want that's weird imagine if we
height map that all right this fractal
Trace
um maybe maybe that's what you want I
don't know it's kind of up to you you
see these a lot you can like sometimes
you can download height maps for like
different areas in the world that Google
has all right but anyway once you get
something you like here I don't want to
go too far into this I can mess with
this forever I'll show you a couple I
generated earlier
just by kind of playing around but at
some point you want to go to colors and
just go to
I guess you could go to I think
brightness contrast I think here
uh yeah you can mess with that if you
want but there's one specific one I was
looking for
tickets Hue saturation we just want to
take the saturation all the way down and
that will just take all the color out so
if you've accidentally got some various
colors in here you can this saturation
and just take it all out obviously it's
not changing this much because I already
started with black and white so there's
not much to change but if there was like
Reds and blues and stuff in there they
would take those out
all right so it's looking all right
maybe I'll hit a few more filters maybe
do another gaussian blur or two
sometimes this kind of helps make it
basically kind of smoother terrain in
the long run just a little bit of blur
in there
something like that
and the last thing I'm do I'm going to
do is I think I'm just gonna just go to
this exposure under colors and just kind
of over expose it a little bit just to
make the blacks more pronounced
um and you kind of play around with this
but this isn't my favorite height map
I've ever made it's very random it's
going to be very messy but it's going to
get the point across as a good demo one
all right and what I like to do here is
I don't know say you want this swamp to
be an island so you can grab one of your
brushes here let's go to airbrush
change this to pitch black and just put
some black around the edges
turn up this hardness
you click somewhere and hold shift you
can do it in Mass you can basically make
some low areas by just darkening them up
this doesn't seem to be going as dark as
I like so maybe we'll go to instead of
airbrush we'll go to paint brush it
should make it a little darker
and I'm just going to kind of surround
it by this dark area just as a low area
you could also if you want it to be
surrounded by mountain or something
light area but that's gonna basically in
my case for what I'm thinking the low
areas are gonna be water you can think
it's going to be like a little island
surrounded by water and if you want to
round it out a little bit you can you
know do some stuff like this
and you can uh you can make some Rivers
this way say you just went like a river
kind of going through like this maybe
another one from over here crosses
through you know something like that and
then you could maybe consider
uh doing more stuff if you want but
personally this is just looking a little
cray-cray in my opinion there's just so
many dark splotches so maybe we can
maybe we can do a few more light areas
just so we'll go to
kind of a grayish color on the white
side here and change this let's go back
to
let's go back to airbrush
and uh
it's kind of lighten these up a little
bit just like so
it's Bob rossett you know just kind of
makes some higher terrain here is the
thought process now once again I'm all
I'm basically just kind of randomly
doing stuff here so use your creativity
not like a master in all this but you
can kind of see we're getting something
here now once again we want to filter it
down a little bit let's go back to the
exposure and uh
mess with these levels a bit
and uh yeah we can kind of keep touching
these levels until we get something that
we think is going to work for us once
again I'm going to pull out the
saturation in case I got some yellows in
there or anything and you can kind of
see by the mini picture what it's going
to look like if you sort of zoom out
you're kind of get an overview looks
something like a maybe like you'd see in
a black and white map right that's kind
of what you want my opinion anyway
so I'm just gonna do a few more things I
think I'm going to hit this gaussian
blur one more time after adding these
Peak zones of light
and there we go that doesn't look too
bad so close enough all right we got a
height map to work with so now we're
just going to go to file export and save
it as something you're going to remember
so I'm going to just put in my created
images and save it as like uh height map
three I've already made a one and two
all right so General so basically step
one get a hype that's really all this
point is and this is just one way you
could do it with campus by playing
around with this kind of stuff so I'll
show you a couple hype Maps I made
previously
so I've got this height map I made
earlier and I've got I've got this one I
kind of made two which you see has some
somewhat mountainous ranges and here's
our new one that I just made all right
so we got some pipe maps to play around
with
now and blender so once you've got a
height map you can open up blender uh
let's let's get rid of this camera let's
get rid of this light you can just click
on them hit delete
so that was just the default of this
house starts out if you haven't changed
anything and let's get rid of this Cube
so now what we want to do is just add a
plane and you can do that when you're in
object mode here
pressing shift a and shift a go to plane
and now we want to scale this up to a
Terrain size because this is really tiny
and you know for thinking terrain for
example we want it to be kind of big so
just hit s and just scale it up I'm
going to scale it by like 500 so I hit
500 enter and now another thing about
blender is when you scale it doesn't
lock in the transformation it just has a
scale applied to the the one by one so
what you got to do is hit I think it's
Ctrl a and then and this is an apply
operation control a all transformations
now you can see the scales one and it
actually resize this entire thing the
rent it goes out of render distance
there a bit because it's huge you might
be able to change that in blender
settings but not a huge deal
all right so now we want to apply our
height map to this plane is what we do
next here so we're going to go over here
to the right side you got to make sure
you have your plane selected and then
you go to this wrench tool the modifiers
properties all right so you click on
that you click on ADD modifier and we're
going to look for under deform a
displace click on displays
and we got some options here we got a
direction and we want our direction to
be Z because that's going to be
blender's height you know that's the up
and down on blender by default you might
have it different like if you use for
example opengl the up and down is the Y
but in blender here it's Z by default
all right space we got local we got a
strength we got a mid-range we can play
around with those later but for now
we're going to just leave them so now
we've got a displace so now this is kind
of interesting you have to actually
click on this place by default it's
already clicked on but if you add more
modifiers for example let's add some
other random thing you can you'll notice
that you can click between that I'll
exit out so just keep that in mind going
forward because that's where people tend
to get stuck because they have the wrong
one selected and the right options
aren't showing so when you have this
displace clicked here you can and you
can tell by the blue outline around it
little blue outline it might be hard to
see on the video but you'll know now
what you want to do is you want to go
down here to a material properties click
on that you click new and you get a
material
no I'm sorry I'm slightly mistaken we
don't want to go to material yet we'll
use that a little later we want to go to
texture properties this should be the
next one down looks like a checkerboard
and you'll see it has display selected
here and we're going to cost
say new and it brings up this now we've
got image or movie by default there's
other options here but we're just going
to leave an image or movie and then down
here with image we're going to go to
open and here's where we want to
navigate through the height map we
created so just go to where you saved it
and there's a little search up here if
you need it all right map we're gonna
pick I map three that's going to bring
it in you'll see it on the right side
nothing looks applied yet that's normal
it's under displace let's go back up
here to displace uh coordinates
coordinates we want to change this to UV
so it's kind of hard to see here because
there's really no lighting so what we're
going to do here is just add a sun we're
gonna once again make sure you're in
object mode hit Ctrl a and look for
light and just put a sun in there and
this sun we can change this direction a
little bit we also want to press Z and
go to rendered that way we'll be able to
see shadows and you can click this
little Sun move it around a little bit
and this should basically allow you to
see your your bumps and your actual
height map a little better with some
shadowing so you can tell what's going
on a little better and we're going to go
to our sun while you have the sun
selected go to the properties of it here
and you could play around with its
strength and its color I'm going to turn
it just a little bit yellow
all right very good as you can see it's
pretty hard to to make note of anything
going on here so far so maybe we'll
change this back to Z see how that looks
we see something shifted there when we
change I could see it a little bit so
it's definitely working it just doesn't
quite look right all right now you may
have already figured this out but
basically This Plane we're working with
here it's only got four vertices it's
got the four corners
that's that's all it has right now so
that's it's only going to allow shifts
based on the vertices so what you need
to do is subdivide it a bunch so we want
to go into edit mode you can press tab
to go into edit mode or you can just
switch it up here and then right click
and click subdivide and subdivide down
here you get a little option and you can
do number of cuts so we're going to take
this number of cuts up to like I don't
know let's do 256. that's a lot of cuts
and you see we get all these little dots
now we can actually height map because
it's going to adjust these vertices to
height map when we only had four
vertices the Four Corners obviously it
couldn't do a whole lot with the hottie
map it was just not enough detail okay
so now with this 256 subdivides we can
go back into object mode and immediately
we can see the height map is being
applied to some extent
and it doesn't look too bad already so
we can we'll adjust our sun maybe a
little bit we just want to be able to I
just like having a sun in here so you
can see the Shadows you don't actually
need the Sun
make sure you're in rendered mode if you
don't see this if you have this it's
solid it's going to look like this which
you know this is a fine way to work too
maybe it's better for you
but totally up to you I just like seeing
it rendered all right so now we can make
sure we got our plane selected go back
to the modifiers and play with the
strength and you can see its actual
operation here
uh there's a negative 100 so when it's
negative it takes all
of the light zones and put some low so
really you can make it either way you
can make the light sink or you can make
the light be mountainous higher region I
like the dark to be the low regions
personally I just think it works better
so let's go back here and let's make
this positive
and that should operate more as we
expect and there we go we got some some
high regions uh where it's lighter
at this point I would love to increase
this render distance a little bit I'm
not sure where you do that and uh I'm
not going to look it up mid video but
it's probably somewhere in preferences
in viewport but I'm not seeing it
so if you know the top of your head just
leave a comment
but you can see we're kind of getting
some things done here all right so what
else do we want to do well we could go
you can right click here and go to shade
smooth kind of get a nicer looking
terrain like so you can see that there's
like some blotchiness and we don't
necessarily want that because these
we're intended to be Rivers but
it's just the way it came out so
different height Maps you're going to
get different different observations but
it's kind of doing what we expect it is
a very blotchy image so not too
surprised that it looks like this if you
have like clean dark lines it'll get
smoother looking Rivers for example so
let me just let me just choose a
different height map here and let's take
a look at what happens so I'm going to
choose this one height map 2 and you can
see that uh it kind of works here
see the mountainous regions you can see
the low regions this isn't the best
detail of a height map either but with
playing around with these levels you
should be able to get kind of pronounced
that you want
so there's definitely a bit of a
bit of a learning curve we'll say or a
bit of a best practices you'll have to
figure out here as far as height maps go
this is one I did earlier
as well that has kind of more pronounced
Rivers it's cleaner looking in general
as you could kind of tell when it was
very messy looking it shows in the
height map and this one you can see it's
got the low edges here with this dark
border
that's what we intended all right so I'm
going to go back to the one I was
messing with before and
we can we can add some more modifiers so
another thing we can do is just go back
to modifiers and add another modifier
called decimate where's
decimate under generate this is going to
give us some more options I'm going to
leave it collapse and we can play around
with this ratio this is basically the
lower this is the more it's gonna kind
of smooth things out a little bit by
just decimating the geometry so you can
kind of play around with that a little
bit as well and you can just kind of see
what works for you you click all these
options and play around you can get an
angle limit here with planner so you can
really kind of modify its end result you
get what you want here
uh let's let's stick with that 0.5 I'm
going to stick with a collapse and then
right click shade smooth
um doesn't look the greatest this looks
pretty messy for a geometry but that's
okay and you can also go to textures
here eventually and add a texture to it
add a material and set it how you want
I'm going to give it maybe just a little
little brown or something a little
orangish I don't know maybe a little
greenish I don't know you decide you
could bring in you know you can go to a
material workflow on this if you will
and you know that kind of gets into a
whole new area but you can go into
shading for example Zoom way out here
and you can start messing with nodes and
you can do special stuff like make maybe
low areas look a certain way or steep
areas look a certain way so you kind of
get that Rocky texture going here if you
get fancy with that
and get fancy with these notes I'm not a
node expert so I'm not gonna try to go
into that right now I'm just keeping it
really simple so let's go back into
layout just switch no not delete switch
this to rendered and you can kind of see
what it might look like as a final
result obviously we got the lighting
being influenced by the Sun so your
results May Vary
this point if you want to use this you
can just go to file export and Export it
as whatever you want I'm going to do a
little obj here and just save it
somewhere I'm just going to call this
demo terrain for example and then you
can load this up in your favorite game
engine
for me I have this uh you know I'm
always working on Graphics as most of
you probably know I'm going to open up
my Archer engine here which is my little
game engine that's perpetually in
progress and I got a startup item here
oh no it's gonna it's gonna build
libraries okay I'm gonna let it do that
real quick but just for sake example you
could you could load up Unity unreal
Godot you name it anywhere you can bring
in a model you should be able to bring
in this and uh kind of make your final
adjustments so I'm just going to launch
my little editor sample thing here in my
project this is on GitHub for free if
you want to toy with it always welcome
to it's always always welcome to
improvements and pull requests and all
that stuff I don't actually have much
time to work on it anymore
looks like I have a break point
accidentally all right so get my little
editor up here it's just a blank screen
um this is just a sample editor I'm
going to go to head to import model and
we're just gonna let my demo brain here
that I saved there it is demo terrain
bring it in oh I've got more break
points I guess I last time I was working
on this I was debugging some alright but
there we are terrain has loaded in just
as I height mapped it that's really the
point of what to show you is that you
can load it in to your software from
there as you want
I'll show you a couple ways a couple
other cool things maybe but hopefully
you get the point of this workflow
making height Maps or downloading them
however you want to get a height map and
then just basically getting a plane in
there subdivide it uh bring in a
displacement modifier
and then go to your material and bring
in the texture that you want and you
know basically playing around with these
settings you want to set it to UV
direction to Z
you know play around with these as
desired obviously it was a bit bumpy
like something like this might be better
to load in but other one was just too
bumpy and then decimate to mess with
stuff's shade smooth to to kind of mess
with it more and you can get fancier
from there if you want
and of course I also just added a
texture for this greenish color or a
material rather so you can get fancy
with that if you're good at that with
with the whole shading workflow and all
that stuff where do you go from here
what other stuff can you do well if you
just do a Google search for like
generating height Maps or height map
generators for example you'll find all
kinds of stuff
you'll find that you know lots of people
have made these kind of
uh height mappers in some games just
allow you to bring them into you bring
in a height map for City skylines for
example it's just gonna it's gonna work
there's there's a lot of tools that kind
of help with this too but you can just
do them manually you can also write your
own I think learn opengl has some
tessellation stuff so
this tutorial here and learn opengl you
know there's a lot of stuff to go
through but they've got some uh kind of
ideas on how to render terrain
dynamically as well
um so if you really want to do it
through pure code this might be a decent
place to start as you can see they've
got some output results and if you put
it in opengl and wireframe mode you'll
see it like that so you know I just want
to you know kind of as a final thing say
blender's not the only option you can
manually code this up because
essentially it just places vertices
based on your preferences and all that
cool stuff so hopefully this helped you
understand height Maps a little bit
maybe get started with them or something
and uh yeah that's all I got we'll see
in the next video peace out guys
thank you